tu es journaliste tu devrais savoir tu
devrais aussi poser des questions on a
su insister d'assaut pourquoi ce que tu
ne poses pas des griffes y en a dit
bonjour laurent richard pour le magazine
envoyé spécial sur france 2 monsieur
président r de one la france l'union
européenne peuvent être décemment vous
faire confiance en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme
sept ans après le début du conflit en
syrie regrettez-vous avoir fourni autant
d'armes
autant de munitions aux groupes
combattants islamistes et d'avoir laissé
passer autant de jihadistes en syrie en
route vers la syrie
par votre pays la turquie la même façon
au regard du risque qui nous préoccupe
tous aujourd'hui le retour des
djihadistes sur le sol européen et en
france entre autres
avez vous oui ou non comme des
informations nous sont parvenues fait
libérer des membres de dèche en échange
la libération du personnel turc du
consulat turc de mossoul dont des
ressortissants européens
avez vous des nouvelles de ces
djihadistes français anglais autrichiens
allemands savez-vous ce qu'ils sont
devenus
et avez vous partager ces informations
avec les services français monsieur ou
président la république française la
france peut-elle faire confiance en soi
votre partenaire turc
considérant le double jeu mené par la
turquie en syrie pendant de longues
années et de son soutien à certains
groupes armés salafistes en syrie merci
budget sur le nous sommes désolé j'ai
pas compris votre souris qui sait qu'ils
envoyaient des armes en série qui a
envoyé des armes en syrie et les il ya
les camions de vos services de
renseignement les services du mythe qui
ont été interceptés en 2014 en eau
décembre 2013 et janvier 2014 sur un
poste frontière et à l'intérieur
desquels on retrouvait les mortiers ces
images ont été filmées vue aurait été
immédiatement censuré gimd
salim des fêtes wars locaux le jeu soit
tu parles comme quelqu'un du faitout
toi tu parles comme quelqu'un du faitout
l'amf est aux anges avec le même
argument je parle comme journaliste au
comminges en année ce n'est pas
exactement comme un membre du ce qu'ils
ont fait cette opération c'était des
procureurs qui était liée au fait tôt
aujourd'hui sont sous état d'arrestation
qui sont en prison les gens qui ont
écouté estime gilles atteint les os les
organisations européennes de
renseignement comme on l'a si la tâche
qu'ils ont des droits ils ont des
devoirs de transporter des armes d'un
coût de l'eau selon les lois been tu me
pose cette question mais des états unis
ont envoyé 4000 camions s'ils en larmes
en syrie pourquoi est ce que tu me pose
pas cette question 4000 camions d'armes
en tenir de ma portée par les états unis
tu es journaliste tu devrais savoir tu
devrais aussi de poser des questions n'a
su insister d'assaut pourquoi est-ce que
tu ne pose pas des questions a dit 4000
camions d'armes ont été enlevés par les
états unis ancien parler de ça écrivait
cela quand vous posez vos questions
il faut être sensible mais ne parlez pas
avec les arguments des zones de progrès
au congrès et bien pas quelqu'un qui va
avaler ces couleuvres facilement face de
vous il faut que vous le sachiez
ça ce sont des arguments rien discours
de fait de bons mots ida et il faut s'il
vous plaît apprendre à ne pas parler
avec sept discours à la fête
donc la réponse était non
il n'y en a pas eu et donc moi ma
réponse peut être oui parce que
aujourd'hui nous travaillons très bien
avec la turquie dans toute la région